we're on the north korean state media
website yesterday's pretty interesting
they announced a visit by comrade leader
kim jong-un to the
pyongyang trolley bus factory
kim the story begins quote looked around
different places of the factory
including processing motor and bus
assembly workshops
to acquaint himself with their
modernization and the actual condition
of production
then he expressed great satisfaction
with the fact that the factory
established an integrated manufacturing
system properly
manufactured modern equipment by itself
and supplemented itself with new
equipment
the story went on like this for several
paragraphs pretty florid you will not be
surprised to learn it was not a hard
hitting piece
on the other hand it wasn't vogue they
didn't go that far
when it comes to authentic state media
cult of personality hero worship the
propagandists in north korea's communist
party news agency
look on in awe at the reporters of vogue
magazine in new york
the vogue guys do stalinism the
old-fashioned way they are
all in they barely use verbs it's all
smoldering hot superlatives
consider the new vogue profile of dr
jill biden
the scholar scientist states person
civil rights icon
healer mother of a nation eternally the
first lady of our hearts
we could go on but vogue already did
dr jill we learned from vogue is quote
driven
tireless effortlessly popular but also
someone who reminds us
of ourselves that's right she's us
but better as vogue puts it she's every
inch a goddess
and a very busy goddess at one point we
find dr jill in reading glasses on air
force one preparing for her negotiations
with other world leaders of the g7
you go dr jill you don't need to be
elected to lead our country
back in the united states dr jill barely
pauses to slip into yet another
glamorous outfit
before heading off to administer
life-saving vaccines to any american who
wants one and even some who don't
dr jill is a doctor first and foremost
in one scene from the vogue piece dr
jill cradles the arms of nervous women
as they get the jab
look at me she could reassuringly it
doesn't hurt
that's right it's only kool-aid drink
the whole cup
as dr jill puts it with her signature
modesty you try to lift up other people
who is this amazing woman this servant
saint humanitarian genius medical
missionary who still
somehow has managed to stay beguilingly
sexy at 69
what did america do to deserve her
well thankfully vogue answers that
question
dr jill the magazine declares is a quote
joy
multiplier she multiplies joy that's
what she does
it's who she is and by the way dr jill
also shot an 18 on the golf course last
week
played the whole round in 22 minutes in
between vaccinations and international
treaty signings
it was a typical day for dr jill
back in north korea they must have read
the latest issue of vogue with their
jaws open
a joy multiplier joy brigade sure
but joy multiplier that might be too far
even for the kim
family north korea may be a hermit
kingdom
but even they're not that stupid hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else